[Music]
[Applause]
first of all I like to ask you a
question what is beauty beauty is a
single word but we use it describe a
billion different things
it is this universal concept has totally
subjective how much you determine if
something else is beautiful
what does it mean when something isn't
beautiful where are my manners a very
good evening to the beautiful ladies or
certainly hands and gentlemen fellow Ted
speakers and everyone present today
throughout our lives we are surrounded
by a cacophony of noise and I guess what
we should do how we should act and who
we should be
now convinced long hair of fair
complexion sexy eyes luscious lips perky
breasts a small waist of flat stomach a
shapely bum long legs finally finishing
with a symmetrical body completely I do
look of a physically perfect woman
however if I were to tell you that
deserves I've only applied to women I
will be lying
[Laughter]
his hair the saddest chaos the eyes
deepen captivating the jawline masculine
chiseled broad shoulders chest muscles
six-pack ABS rippling biceps a wide back
oh and he must be 6 feet in love from
the broad chest the Superman tiny waves
of Disney Princesses our perception of
beauty has been so greatly influenced by
the media that we subconsciously accept
give requirements as being true and just
therefore now these people are boycotted
isolated discriminated even because they
are thought of as ugly or different so
that matter and that's why in a pursuit
of beauty super tend to go overboard and
finally become something to not 12 years
ago The Swan took the world by storm
being described by Jennifer Potter as
the most sadistic reality show of the
decade and the Swan is a 2004 American
reality television program at which
women who in judged to be ugly with
extreme makeovers to fulfill to create
fantasies contestant collectively
received four in four million dollars
worth of treatment including tummy tucks
breast augmentations rhinoplasty draw
and nose reconstruction laser hair
removal of the say extremely complicated
and time-consuming process not to
mention the agonizing physical pain
these people have to endure over two
months some of them were happy that's
good
but for some
relationships crumbled some gained
weight
some of them conjugated suicide after
some of them or they still suffer from
depression agoraphobia in crippling
mental disorders this might seem Stagg
relays and gentlemen just pounds of
individuals squealed in the light when
they were told that they were chosen to
become a swan because they were sick of
being called ugly they were sick of
insecure marriages and this is the
product of our beauty obsessed culture
yet another blight that consumed so many
young people is an erection nervosa and
eating disorder that is characterized my
sphere of waiting leading to
malnutrition or excessive weight loss
kirsten Hagman was 19 when she became
Miss America in 2008 was the youngest
beauty queen ever to win the national
title if she was the victim of anorexia
she now uses this platform of her title
to raise awareness about this very
sensitive subject she was the
disturbing disorder since the age of 12
consume you filled the nine hundred
calories daily lesson happy my
recommended for the average woman her
age she became obsessed the need to
reduce early even further starving
herself and adding even more exercise
for regular routine and manic schedule
she arrived to a newly reversible
condition if not for the help of a motor
and multiple specialists she would have
reached a point of no return and all
this is for the sake of fitting yourself
into the image of beauty inculcated into
her mind but a question with stands of
our society from time to time
I wonder why do we hold physical place
at such high regard
do we not realize that what's inside is
far more important I mean you might have
a participation of looking great and you
might have that satisfaction of
splitting into a smaller shirt but
besides somebody you change your
appearance what else does that say about
you now let me show you guys something
especial something you might not believe
so this is me when I was ten years old
as you can see I was fat like really
really fat but I didn't bother I mean I
take tennis and badminton everything but
man I just love eating so I just ate and
a I got fatter and fatter it's a review
well you sit down all of a sudden you
see I completely forgot I look like this
I thought what are y'all going to old
photos I guess well like oh my goodness
I rush to mom I said mom how could you
let me look like this but shoot puzzled
and said look like what this this she
laughed and said oh keep me looking fat
Ryan you're my son I love you and
nothing who ever change that
and it was at that moment I just got it
look I was more than just a fat kid I
was positive I was cheerful I was
helpful I might not have had the best
physique we're going to study that is
but I have never liked friends
throughout my life I have always had
happy people around me
however you may look like on the outside
it is your character that makes you
truly fine ladies and gentlemen do we
love others just because it looks don't
we love them because of who they are
deep within would we stop loving them as
they gain a few pounds developed acne
stopped putting on makeup or cut their
hair a famous player at once wrote do I
love you because you are beautiful or
are you beautiful because I love you
these words affect the idea that beauty
is purely subjective now I can come from
appreciation
I'm just the other way around we need to
educate our children and grandchildren
that physical characteristics alone do
not constitute the beauty really change
and we need it now
friends Spain iliyan Israel have enacted
legislation banning overly skinny models
empowering half size such as honor my
curves
there's wear and celebrate my sides have
blown up or Instagram body paws
movements are celebrated everywhere and
this is a good thing the body positive
movement is a movement that encourages
people to adopt a more affirming
attitude towards their bodies over goals
improving over a health and fitness
because whether it would live peacefully
inside our own bodies only then we are
able to care for others from point of
love and appreciation we need more
diverse models in the media but in terms
of race high body size skin color be it
black white brown or yellow red or green
or blue or polka-dotted whatever we need
diversity because this world is diverse
man
people are diverse don't get me wrong
there is nothing wrong with being skinny
or putting on makeup but there is
nothing wrong with being not skinny and
not putting our makeup I'll tell you
what if you want to put on weight you
put on weight if you want to slim down
you slim down you're going to hit the
gym you hit the gym if you want to put
on makeup every day you put on makeup
every day if you want to dye your hair
and rainbow colors I don't see why not
be whoever you want to be because that
is who you truly are beauty is
everywhere and inside everyone we may
not be able to see inner beauty in
person but we can definitely feel it I
would like to leave you with these
beautiful words bye pull it and handsome
you're made of so much beauty but it
seems that you forgot when you decided
and you were defined by all the things
you're not whoever they are whatever
they may say be strong be different be
beautiful thank you
[Applause]